okay why don't we go ahead and get
started U Want to welcome everyone to um
Nathan lazar's PhD
Symposium uh which as many of you know
is is one of the steps along the way to
doing dissertation which usually
involves
backgrounding background information
formate
ET so um Nathan is a student in the BCB
track he did his undergraduate work at
Ohio College Ohio Ohio University sorry
and then I got a
masters at Port State and has been in
our program both program and funded by
the nlm
training thank you all for
coming um it's nice to see everybody
here for me um so it's a symposium talk
so it's kind of just an overall gener
General overview of what the field that
I kind of want to go into for my thesis
work um so I'm going to be talking about
um graphical modeling and spatial
interactions on kind of a subcellular
level um so space
right oh is this always cut off I guess
all my headings are going to be slightly
cut off so here's the over
um talk about kind of the goal of the
research or the first uh uh problem that
we look to tackle um some of the data
that uh is coming available here at OSU
which is pretty exciting a lot of this
stuff is really cutting edge um
including floressence microscopy
electron microscopy super resolution
fluoresence microscopy and combining
those two and then I'll talk about some
of the possible ways to model those
things um using different spatial
statistics and graphical models you know
difficulties and then thanks and at the
bottom this says
Pizza all right so motivation for doing
this is sometimes cells go crazy and try
to take over the
world um one of the ways that they do
this uh is through this um egfr
signaling pathway this is really is
there any way to change that
screen I'm going to miss all my uh
sources and
stuff if I just
do
guess I should have checked this before
I started but
didn't
I think it's it's
extended you can't
see okay I guess
that's I guess there's nothing we can do
so um egfr signaling is kind of the big
problem that the Joe Greg lab has been
working at so all all this Imaging type
data is kind of centralized around this
idea
um so this is a pathway um that
basically is how the cell one of the
ways that a cell decides to start
dividing um so these receptors on the
surface of the cell egfr receptors um
they are bound by some growth hormone um
and then create this uh through a chain
of interactions with other proteins
phosphor and dimerizations
have the signaling Cascade going down
into the nucleus which initiates the
proliferation of the cell um and this is
a big problem because um these uh these
receptors are mutated um in a large
amount of cancers and normally mutated
so that they're kind of stuck in the on
position which gives you the flu of
growth in cancer when you didn't want
it um so it's mutated the something in a
signaling pathway the her two signaling
molecules up here or some of these um in
that family are mutated in about 20% of
breast cancers and not only are they
mutated but they are become resistant to
treatment um in 90% of cases and the
regression free survival time is only
about 10 months um so this is basically
like what we know about this signaling
Cascade at this
point where um her two kind of dimerizes
with her3 or
egfr and has all these interactions with
these different possible signaling
molecules going down into the nucleus to
to turn on
proliferation um we have drugs that
Target the that stop the signaling stop
the uh binding of the um the molecule
that induces signaling but as I
mentioned like the the cancers become
resistant to this quickly so clearly
this type of picture isn't good enough
to really um addressing this by itself
isn't good enough to to stop these
cancers
so what's missing from this picture well
we just have like okay some stuff on the
membrane and then cytool this giant uh
component of the cell that doesn't have
any information on where exactly these
different proteins are located we don't
know anything about organel or vesicles
or how these things are transported in
there what actually physically is going
on we can't see that stuff yet or we
couldn't we're starting to be able to
now so uh we need some data toy to
understand these physical relationships
that's the wrong kind of data um so for
starters the I guess simplest approaches
fluoresence microscopy this is an image
from the human protein
Atlas um where the there's been a stain
for the nucleus in Blue uh red as
microtubules um and then the green is a
stained for her too so you can see that
it's localized mostly on the membrane um
but it depends on the cell type and
they've the human protein Atlas has
thousands of different proteins
characterized in this way but we still
can't see organel we can see kind of
generally where they're located um in
these two dimensional pictures and kind
of correlate the locations of different
proteins but we can't see individual
interactions we can't see dimerization
we can't see who's phosphor relating who
or what complexes are built there and
how they interact with the different
compartments of the
cell
so how could we see that stuff maybe
with an electron microscope uh this was
the first one in North America that's in
Canada um electron microscope can see on
a much smaller scale because the
wavelength of light is too big to see
these individual particles interact but
the wavelength of electrons if you think
of them as a wave is much smaller so an
electron microscope you accelerate some
electrons and instead of using uh glass
to focus them you use magnetic fields
and you pass those through a sample
sample and collect the electrons that
either go through the sample or bounce
off of it with different detectors and
then you can see at much smaller scales
than you could see with
light so here's an image from an
electron microscope looking at the same
problem with the her two another name
for that is the
erbb2 um and in this case those uh
particular proteins have been uh stained
well there's an antibody that recognizes
her2 and conjugated to that antibody is
a gold particle um in this case they're
10 nanometers these little black dots
each one of those is a tiny particle of
gold so we can see individual molecules
because they've been uh recognized by
this antibody with the gold
particle um and this diagram here is
like of one cell where on one side of
the cell this is pretty common in these
types of images when you're looking at
um cells that have her two signaling
part of the cell will have this kind of
ruffled appearance with these filipodia
like
projections and maybe the other side of
the cell will be flat and this study
found that the philipo like projections
tends to have a lot higher concentration
of those her two molecules um so there
must be some connection between this
ruffling and the signaling of the herto
molecules but uh we haven't really
modeled yet the actual shape of the of
the surface or how these connections are
interdependent on each
other um and the other thing with the
electron microscope right it has to be
in black and white there's not different
colors of electrons um so we can't do
the same kind of staining thing to see
different components of the cells um and
there's only so many I've only seen
studies with maybe two different types
of gold particles labeled of different
sizes so you can see maybe two
individual proteins at a time different
classes of proteins at a time to see
whether they interact with each other
but we can't go beyond that at this
point um some more of the microscopes
this is a oh and that was a 2D image
right this is a um Helios nanolab um
machine that we have here at
OHSU um and it's a focused ion beam
combined with a scanning electron
microscope sorry yeah combined with the
scanning electron microscope they call
it slice and
view um and this can see in three
dimensions by taking your sample you
kind of carve a trench out around the
place that you're interested in and then
the focus ion beam can shave off
incredibly thin slices of the sample and
then you image with the Electron Beam so
you take a picture shave off a slice
take another picture shave off another
slice and by doing that you can build
these 3D reconstructions of where
exactly all these organel and and sub
cellular uh compartments
are so when you do that this is the kind
of image you get off of that um each one
of these is a slice as you can see
they're not all perfectly aligned and
they tend to have different contrast
levels um and we're actually moving
through the sample it's not refreshing
as fast as it should but we're moving
through the sample with each new picture
which is hard to tell because they're
that thin that the stuff doesn't even
seem to change from picture to picture
the slices can be as small as four
nanometers which is on the scale of you
know the size of a protein or protein
complex and each pixel here is about 4
ners as well so you get spatial
resolution in all three dimension that's
about the same size which is
Inc this is a reconstruction by Danielle
JG and Jessica rer who obtained the
images of uh breath cancer cell line the
one we saw previously was a pancreatic
tumor um but this is a breast cancer
cell line that's been grown in matrigel
which is a 3D gel for mice that you can
grow cells in to recapitulate kind of
their full 3D shape
um she was looking at this these same
filipodia like projections that we're
interested
in um and she goes through each one of
these images and segments out using
something like Photoshop to draw the
outlines and then can build 3D 3D models
of exactly what these shapes look like
so those protrusions are the filipodia
leg projections the orange here is just
a graded matri gel and the yellow
spheres are U are vesicles that are
probably transporting molecule in or out
of the
cell we don't have any tag molecules
here so we don't know exactly what
molecule we're looking at being
transported in and out of the cell but
this is just to demonstrate some of the
3D
capabilities um I can't even pause this
because I guess I
can so just want to orient you a bit too
like this is one nucleus here and this
is the Border in between some cells so
one of the difficulties here I mean she
just segmented a small part of this here
but one of the difficulties is kind of
telling where one cell ends and the
other begins um so if we really want to
characterize the interaction between
these cells a perfect segmentation of
those details would be
great um and there's people working on
that but it's a really tough problem and
I think that some of the segmentation
can be combined with some of the
modeling we don't need to have
absolutely perfect segmentation in order
to be able to learn stuff from this um
but this is a a fast growing area on how
exactly to work with these images and
characterize all the tiny things that is
going on
here
um another uh electron microscope that
we have here at Hsu from fi um this
one's a tomography
um microscope and what that means is you
take your sample and tilt it 70° in
either direction while taking images
from from the electron microscope which
you can then back project in order to
construct a thinner
three-dimensional volume of the
cell so this is a reconstruction uh
after the back projection and and
reconstruction of the 3D image we're
slicing through here and then um
outlining the different vesicles in this
case the light light brown is the an
outer double membrane vesicles Pinker
smaller vesicles were some viral rep
application is going on Brown is
endoplasmic reticulum and blue is some
intermediate
filaments um and green you can see a
little bit that's Goldie oh by the way I
forgot to mention please ask questions
if you have any while I'm going makes me
more
comfortable um so this is a study using
uh Tom electron tomography along with
some of this gold Nano Nano labeling
done by one of our collabor Ator Yan
post who is at utri University in the
Netherlands um and the big gold dots
here are just fiducial markers so you
can tell where you are in each uh image
so that you can align these
threedimensional U these different
projections in in order to tell where
everything is um and then the small uh
gold Nano label Dots here are labeling
calvan which is a marker for these Calvi
um kind of invaginations from the
membrane uh membrane bound vesicles as
they're going into the
cell and he's trying to understand how
uh certain molecules pass through the
cell by coming into these vesicles and
then those vesicles moving from one side
of the cell to the
other um but you can see you know um in
particular this protein tends to once
you do the segmentation in 3D
reconstruction you can see how this
protein tends to form along the outside
of these uh vesicles but not along the
membrane in general but even in his talk
here which was two weeks ago or so he
mentioned how there was difficulties in
quantifying exactly the distribution of
these individual particles and trying to
understand where they are and where they
aren't what we would expect to see if
they were randomly distributed and so
forth all right so um the problems with
electron microscopy although we can see
3D and in super high resolution we can
only see in black and white um and we
can only mark one protein or maybe two
proteins at a time so maybe we can
combine light microscopy with electron
microscopy so that we can see a bunch of
different types of proteins at the same
time in different colors as long as we
can overlay the electron the fluorescent
image with the electron
image um so this is this clam stands for
correlated light an electron microscopy
which is up here you can't see
um but uh this is kind of How It's been
used so far you take an image um where a
protein of Interest has been either
tagged with an antibody that's
conjugated to a a Flor for in this case
green floresent protein or some trans
transgenic Gene that expresses the
protein that
glows and then you use that image to
guide you in looking at the sample with
the higher powered electron microscope
so that these are you know areas of
interest in this case this was viral
replication again um so we can see the
the green Gene was part of the virus
replication mechanism so we can tell
that the virus is replicating in these
areas and then zoom in with the electron
microscope to see okay is this happening
in certain vesicles or in mitochondria
or
what all right but the resolution of
light is not that great right that's why
we're doing electron microscopy in the
first place but maybe we can find a way
to go P that um wavelength of light and
actually use light to identify
individual molecules so that's the super
resolution light
microscopy and the technique that's been
used here by shaol and nonan in Joe's
group who heading this is uh it's called
Palm for photoactivated localization
microscopy and the idea behind that is
um like if we look at just these say
fibers here at a we can tell that
there's two different fibers but by B
the overlap of the spectrum from the the
two emitting for fors um is so high that
we can't really tell whether there's two
things here or one right that's where
our resolution breaks
down and so that's happening around the
defraction limit which is about the size
of a mitochondria shown here and what we
really want to see is individual
proteins around the size of a couple
manometers um so how do we uh get this
resolution to be higher the idea is is
to
um get Flores that flash basically or
can be um excited by a certain
wavelength in a controlled controlled
way so that if we have two molecules
next to each other that are both tagged
with this protein they won't always be
flashing at the same time so maybe we'll
see a flash in one place and then
another flash slightly next to it and we
collect a whole stack of these
images and get a distribution of where
these flashes are occurring and assuming
that that distribution is an a gaussian
curve we can fit it to a nice smooth
model and take the center of that curve
to be the location of one in particular
Flor so we can separate two molecules
that were so close together that we
couldn't tell the difference from one
image by using through time that's
flashing in a in a whole stack of images
and by doing that we can take what would
be this is just one image from
fluorescent microscope and get down to
actually being able to see um what a
reproduction of this is not just one
image it's a reconstruction of you know
from a whole stack of images of where
individual molecules um Li
yes same experiment yeah so it's the
same sample and while it's sitting there
the Flores are flashing you take a bunch
of pictures and each time it flashes it
looks like slightly different position
but that distribution center of it tells
you where
the you any other
question all
right um so this is the um only study
that I know about where it's combining
electron microscopy with this Palm
method
um and you can see in the background is
kind of a low resolution electron
microscopy image um in the foreground we
have a higher resolution electron
microscopy image we're looking at one
bacteria here you can see its cell
membrane um it's been segmented um
so that we can see these vesicles in
White in green or some filament bundles
in blue is this tubular structure that
the researchers were interested in and
individual molecules labeled in the red
and yellow from the uh Palm technique
can be localized exactly on that kind of
blue structure so this really
combination of uh both of these
techniques with super resolution light
and electron microscopy just brand new
and the um the idea behind this is to to
be able to do this we got or Joe got a
million dollar Grant from the kek
foundation which is kind of the outline
of what got me started um thinking about
this
stuff okay but part of that was how do
we really understand these relationships
between all these things so how are we
going to do the
modeling all right so before we can
really start modeling we need to
understand whether the spatial
distributions make
sense um or if they're uh randomly if
the particles that we're looking at are
randomly distributed or
not so uh this is on the left we have
what's considered a complete spatial
Randomness so this means that the
probability of any two particles um
being within a certain distance is has a
poonian
distribution um so this is the kind of
background model of just saying if we
were to randomly Place dots on a grid
this was what you know something of what
they'd look like this one looks more
clustered and but this one looks still
pretty random but it's not so I'll
explain that minute so one way to
measure that is by using um Hopkin's
statistics or Ripley's K and this is a
difference between the expected value
and the actual observed value of these
distances so in this it's close to zero
we start getting some Edge effects as we
look at different larger
distances um which is something that you
have to take into account with these
types of studies but mainly we'd say
this is randomly distributed because
it's around zero these guys look
clustered um because the uh distances we
see more particles at a smaller distance
than we would expect by chance and here
we see less particles at given distances
than we'd expect by chance so the value
is actually below zero which means this
is more uh the particles are more
regularly placed than we would
expect um that's called a hardcore model
um because it could mean that there's
something actually preventing these
molecules from getting too close to each
other some type of Hardcore that we're
labeling here um so these type of
Statistics can tell us about the
distributions of the proteins um and
then we can connect that with the
subcellular features that we see from
like the electron
micrographs um and just an interesting
side note is that a lot of these kind of
things were developed in like forestry
and geological techniques and trying to
understand threedimensional distribution
of you know of different deposits of ore
or gold or in the forestry example
looking at where different types of
trees are and whether they're clustered
next to each other which I was thought
was cool looking through the
literature so here's one study um again
looking at her too and whether it forms
uh diers we're just looking at the
surface of the cell here and in
different treatment conditions we can
quantify um whether these her two
molecules are more clery than we'd
expect to see by chance and whether that
kind of clustering changes uh with
different
treatments so in this case there's not
much difference between whether the SE
the inhibitor is present or not um in
the clustering of these her two
molecules in this case the her two
molecules have been double labeled with
two different size gold beads um and
this is their quantification of it this
is the actual distribution of distances
between each other and this is what you
would expect by chance so you can put
some statistics on
this this is from uh the same study um
but now looking at whether these her two
molecules are forming diers with her
three molecules so they've labeled um
her two it's best to just look at this
picture her two in the small uh gold
Nano gold dots and the larger gold dots
are are three so we can look at the
distribution of both of these sets of
dots and see if they overlap in a way
yeah how many gold
dots oh so the distribution is the
distances pairwise distances between two
dots all of them that you're looking at
so you look at all your dots measure
their distance to the closest
one oh so there's super small ones maybe
you can't see them that well so there's
big ones and small
ones okay and this image isn't
representative of all the data this is
just one
image all right so we can look at the
spatial distribution of these things and
and uh try to combine that with the uh
different compartments of the cell or
different subcellular features that we
know are present based on the electron
images if we can put all this stuff
together um so this is another spatial
resolution this was a paper by Shaolin
Nan um here at OSU looking at in this
case Ras dier formation so this is
without the signaling molecule the RAS
diers are or the RAS molecules are
fairly evenly distributed um after the
signaling molecule they start to form
the these diers which can be Quantified
here um using that Ripley K measure or
he actually came up with another measure
based on DB scan that was uh pretty cool
that can show that he's seeing an
increase in the number of
dimers more than you would expect by
chance in these different
conditions but again like in this we're
only seeing the super resolution
microscopy images these aren't overlaid
with uh the E images em images so we
don't know if these diers to form pre
preferentially in certain parts of the
cell whether they're on these filipodia
like projections and things like
that okay so graphical
modeling um one way to try to combine
all this all these different types of
information in order to make some
coherent statements about what's
influencing what is to use these kind of
abstract graphical models um this is
another image from the human protein
Atlas and it's just representative of
some of the data that people people have
used for some of the um spatial modeling
so far so this is from the Murphy Group
which is uh out of carnegi
melon and apparently he was the formed
the first uh computational biology
program or in the country and it has
probably hundreds of papers on trying to
model these facial interactions but only
from these this uh fluoresence
microscopy types of images it's not
super high
resolution so what they generally
is take their images and extract some
type of features um sometimes on a perel
basis sometimes on a pixel basis of
where things are uh located and what
colors what proteins are located next to
each other and the human protein Atlas
has thousands of these so you can look
at um whether certain proteins tend to
be localized correlate their expression
correlates with between the two groups
and use that to get an idea of where
proteins might be expressed in the
cell um so you extract those features
that might be about the size or
morphology or
intensity um on this fairly U fairly
broad
level and then build some
model whether it's a regression or a
vector machine hidden Markov model that
you train with these features that
you've extracted and then that model um
when you look at it understand the
dependencies in there can tell you
something about how these proteins are
distributed or classify proteins into
certain um types of distributions or
generate hypothesis on what interacts
with what and what these things are
actually
doing so this would be the same kind of
General framework that I want to use but
the data the images that I'll use be
different and the types of uh features
that I'll be able to extract also would
be on a much higher more granular level
uh one way of incorporating these
spatial creatures is to do this kind of
tiling this is from a study looking at
hrop embryos where they did this
triangulation of the space of the embryo
and stretch things out a little bit so
that they could get a feature Vector
basically of each of these triangles and
where the proteins are located and then
correlate those spatial locations
between different types of
proteins um so I think something similar
although it have to be more flexible
would be possible looking at individual
cells under different treatment groups
or um looking at the expression of
different
proteins so what is this gra graphical
modeling
stuff um so we have a bunch of
quantities that we don't know that can
have some value so in this case maybe
this is a binary whether the growth
signal is present um and maybe this is
some measure on how uh much the her two
molecules are enriched on those
filipodia
projections and there's some complicated
uh distribution joint Distribution on
the values of all these different nodes
in this case the gray nodes are things
that have been observed and the white
nodes are things that we perhaps haven't
observed that we still might be able to
infer something about based on their
joint
probabilities so these are all connected
in some way if I change one of these all
these other guys change this is a
complicated um thing to try to untangle
but given enough data to train the model
um as you look through you can perhaps
Whittle down these connections to um
find out which connections are really
direct connections and which are
indirect connections so if there's not a
line in between two things here it means
that they're conditionally independent
if I know what's going on with the other
nodes that they're connected to I don't
need to know what's going on with the
volume of the cell for instance in in
the filipodia all the information about
the volume of the cell is being
transmitted through this Toros or
curvature of the membrane in order to
change this this
value so these can be trained with data
and in in this case this might um give
you some insight as to what's really
going on here whereas previously we
might have thought like okay the growth
signal directly influences uh dimer
formation but maybe the model will tell
us that no the growth signal only CH
changes the ruffling of the membrane and
that has an effect on the amount of her
two and that tells us how much these
diers will form
so we can use this for hypothesis
generation and
classification of different types of
things and try to understand the sit the
um the full system in a way that might
not be possible just by looking at
it um this is an example of one of the
earliest types of these graphical models
from 1994 out of Stanford um so the
previous one is kind of toy and this is
maybe more what they might look like
with a huge amount of different nodes
all interconnected
this is an overview of just some of
these types of graphical models um so
maybe you've seen naive Bays before
logistic regression um in in all of
these the gray dots are things that are
known and the white dots are things that
we're trying to to understand or predict
um so with naive Bays we have a bunch of
knowns and one unknown that we're trying
to predict same with logistic regression
um but in in the top row here we have
this directional where we believe at
least that one node directly causes the
other node to have a certain value um in
the bottom row we don't have that
directionality we just believe in some
um dependency between the the values of
each of the nodes and each of these
little squares black squares represents
that there's just some function of the
things that it's connected to that we
incorporate in the model and are able to
train and learn from from
data in a hidden Markov model we have
more than one we have these hidden set
of states that we don't know the values
for and observations that we can see and
we are trying to infer the most probable
set of States ordering of States uh from
those that we observe um kind of
similarly with a linear chain
conditional random field however that
can have dependencies on previous states
where the hidden marov model the
probability of transitioning from one
hidden state to another is fixed
regardless of the observ
or regardless of which where you are in
the
chain um we can get more General by
allowing connections between um our
observed States or arrows um in the
nonlinear fashion between the unobserved
states and even more General by allowing
higher order interactions more than just
binary uh or directed interactions in
this case we have three nodes
influencing this one function um which
is part of the decomposition of that
probability that that joint probability
over all
nodes so there's a bunch of different
types of models uh graphical models like
this people have been inventing new ones
it seems like every couple weeks but
they all are have the same idea of kind
of decomposing this distribution across
all the nodes and trying to understand
the connections better and they allow
for more flexibility uh with more
complicated models and some of them even
allowing you to add unobserved nodes as
needed
um which can the more flexible the model
basically the more data that you need to
train it normally so which model I will
use to train this kind of depends on
what the data looks like in terms of
distributions of different proteins and
organel and
such um then I just have a list of some
of these hidden uh logistic regressions
basian Nets Markov random Fields uh
discriminative random Fields hidden
conditional random fields and infinite
conditional random Fields um all of
which yeah have the same general
structure but get more
complicated um so this is an example
from some Imaging uh trying to
understand image analysis using Markoff
random fields or discriminative random
fields and the difference between the
two is a discriminate random field can
take into account uh the neighbors of a
specific node so in the first case on
the left here we're trying to
reconstruct these are our original
images we add a bunch of noise and then
we're trying to get back the original
image after just by looking at the image
with the noise um this is the result
from the markof random field which just
tells each pixel whether it should be
black or white and it makes that
decision based only on what's inside the
pixel itself or small area itself
whereas the discriminative random field
can look at its neighbors and tell
what's going on so in this case the the
job was to try to discriminate man made
objects from natural objects and the
discriminative random field allowing
that um being able to look at its
neighbors gives it more power in order
to pull out these types of interactions
so a spatial model in cells would also
have more power being able to look at
its neighbors and tell you um you know
whatever outcome we're trying to look
for this one is
it yeah it's a binary decision yeah for
this one for these
squares yeah yeah it has to make a
decision yeah so it's like a it's like
an a logistic regression but more
compated all right so um once we have
this kind of model where we can
understand things it it might not be
enough to just look at the model in
order to say what's going on so maybe we
could do some type of simulation to see
where we would expect given this model
where we would expect to see certain
proteins in some cellular model this is
from uh an older paper um from 2008
where the kind of shape of the cell is
set but you can use partial differential
equations to kind of explore where uh we
would expect to see a distribution of
different proteins some more advanced uh
modeling where that allows for the shape
of the cell itself to change um was done
in this paper
um just in 2012 and they built these
kind of threedimensional models of cells
that were the where the shape of the
cell depended on what was in each of the
threedimensional
boxal um these are fairly easy to access
so um given some model we'd be able to
kind of sim simulate some of these
things through some web
interfaces all right that says potential
difficulties so the registration which
is just lining up up the images can be
difficult and the segmentation is a big
problem um it's being worked on here by
Gom but um I think that we'll be able to
combine some of the modeling with the
segmentation step so that we don't have
to have perfect segmentation like I
mentioned
earlier um there's always in building a
model you always have to kind of decide
um whether you want a discret versus
some continuous type of data most of
these graphical models depend on some
descritization of the the data going
into each of these nodes
um so that will be a decision I'll have
to make in building the model and then
training is always a a big problem you
need some defined end goal that makes
sense and we need enough data to be able
to train however complicated of a model
I decide to use so simplifying
assumptions might be necessary um I
might be able to use uh feature
selection procedures or information from
previous studies um kind of uh that we
could leverage or information from lower
resolution images like human protein
Atlas that we could leverage in order to
understand some of these reactions or
narrow down some of the possible
graphical models as we're trying to
train and then interpreting um can be
difficult uh but running simulations is
one possibility to help interpret the
model that I come up
with so um overall we're trying to move
from this kind of idea of these
signaling Pathways to incorporate some
real space aspects using these Imaging
data um so that and this higher
resolution imaging data that can be
marked perhaps with a super resolution
light microscopy of different species of
proteins so we can actually tell where
things are what's interacting with what
in what component of the cell and really
improve this uh this model A Lot in the
hopes that uh we can start shrinking
tumors and keeping them away for good
and killing these Rogue Napoleon cells
and not letting them come
back
so that like the thank on my committee
members and the cabone lab and the
demise Department my fellow fellows for
helping me listen to this talk and
giving me advice and Joe gray for
starting the impetus for this um all
this really incredible technology that
I'm really excited to work with u the uh
Imaging from Dan that I showed you the
movies and damir and Michelle were also
helpful to talk to about what type of
projects are
possible um my funding is from nlm the
kek foundation gave the grant that
really spurred a lot of this work on the
her two stuff imaging technology is all
from fi and
Intel is in the process of building a a
big cluster for us so that I'll be able
to use that to actually train my models
on these huge data sets
um so any questions thank you kind of
went
fast yes so what what are some of the
biological discoveries and
ultimately Medical Treatments that would
emanate from I I would understand the
the value of you know understanding
things but what would come forth from
potentially come for from
so I think that um I mean in terms of
like targeting the certain therapies so
right now for instance for the her two
like we have therapies that'll stop the
her2 signaling or stop it from forming
these dimers but that's not enough like
the cells are finding a ways around that
so there's something that we're not
taking into account which is probably
these spatial aspects so there might be
something that doesn't pop up in the gws
or something that's mutated because it's
a normal function of the cell that's
being co-opted by some of these so we
have a different maybe targeting it to a
specific cellular component or it may be
understanding more about like how the
cell morphology changes that if we could
like Joe gives this example like if we
could cut off the filipodia he he talks
about it like a power line instead of
just trying to stop the electricity
going through the power line cut off the
whole Tower and then you stop the the
signal transmitting um so I think that
it just really opens up our eyes in
terms of what to attack with a
therapeutic um instead of just try to
stop this Gene from expressing or try to
stop we don't know where where these
diers are forming we don't know what's
phosphor relating what necessarily or
where all the time so I think it there's
a just a huge amount of possibilities in
terms of targeting for
therapies yes
J
yeah so it could be that it happens in
different compartments of the cell
and perhaps yeah but um I mean I think
like in order for any reaction to happen
like you need a certain concentration of
those molecules to be present right so
there can be you know something about
this the cell morphology that allows for
a higher concentration in a certain area
that we haven't been able to capture
before we could think of that as an
organel or it could just be like some
you know something to do with the
morphology of the shell of the cell
itself
the heart of
father
okay maybe
it's yeah I mean you're right that it's
not um very totally formulated at this
point and I mean I'm not going to be
able to drive the acquisition of the
Imaging stuff so it's it's more a matter
of like what will be available um so in
the krant I mean they talk about the
integrating the super resolution light
microscopy and the EM images um s around
this her two signaling pathway and then
the piece of that that's kind of at
least in my opinion very vague is how
they're going to do the modeling
reconstruction of of that and that's
where I want to come into it like how
are we going to understand the
relationship between those you know say
we can we can tag eight or 10 or 20
different proteins and understand their
um cellular localization in this pathway
in this her two pathway um then we'll be
able to see like when when they interact
with each other and what components of
the cell um and and how that differs
between Cancer and normal cells or
between the side of the cell that has
the ruffling or the side of the cell
that's flat
um so not sure if that totally answers
your question but I'm also not super
clear on exactly what I'll be able to do
given the data that's available
youe
many
multiple
Imes you're very dense in terms of the
image processing you're doing in a
single
experiment yeah so I think that that's a
really good point and it's something
that U we definitely need to keep in
mind and I think one of the ways of
doing that is to incorporate into those
graphical models what we know about
condition and such um so ideally you
know we have
different conditions different cell
lines I mean we're seeing differences
just from the fluoresence microscopy
between cell lines and localization of
her two or whatever um so yeah I mean I
think it's important to keep in mind
that we need to look at a a broad
spectrum of different cell whether it be
cell lines or tissues um and to
incorporate that in the graphical model
as a predictor of the different
behaviors that we're looking
at
yes
yeah yeah so I mean also I mean dealing
with these images these are really high
like you know images a really high
resolution and if you want to get like a
whole cell you're tiling you know dozens
of these images across each other
stacking up the three dimension
of it it's just a huge amount of data to
sort through so extracting the features
from the from the Imaging modalities as
a first step takes a lot a lot of
computing which can be done in parallel
um and is perfect for the type of
cluster that we should be getting we're
building from Intel and then secondly
training the model incorporating
information from all these um hopefully
a lot of different Imaging sources and
different conditions and different
signaling
um yeah there's there's some there's
some stuff in place um and yeah there's
people working on it in terms of the
image segmentation and stuff U there's
people here that are working on
parallelizing I mean for the most part
there there is some some paralyzed codes
but it's pretty young like it's not it's
not fully
mature but yeah that's a concern I mean
I guess in general I'm a little worried
about like you know thing like waiting
for certain steps in order to go next to
the modeling but um I also think that
it's worth while to kind of simulate
some type of data in order to build
models that make sense first or use
lower resolution data from protein Atlas
or from some of the micro environment
arrays or something like that to build
similar models
um before if if it's you know we're
really finding that this is taking a
long time to get this type of the type
of data that we're I'm hoping
for
yeah yeah for
sure
yeah yes come on um so you remarked that
you won't have a lot of
control experim are going be done be
lines
or combinations but don't you think that
once the initial sort of thing comes out
and U somebody will need to generate
hypothesis right so your models could
actually um if they sort of integrate
the data and suggest new things don't
you think
New Generation new hypothesis and yeah
absolutely and that's that's one of the
advantages of the graphical model I mean
understanding that can really lead to
hypothesis generation and yeah I mean
that would that would be
ideal